i was just cutting my buns
are you just cutting your bun okay i
have a um
a wrap a low calorie wrap because
sometimes the bread is a little bread
you know sometimes we don't need it but
i'm gonna do it on a flat wrap okay
okay
so this is a
i've already cooked the onions the
vidalia onions
with the with the steak
and i also put
my cheese on the bottom of my rack
so that it can melt properly and and
guess what else too girlfriend you could
have tomatoes pickles raw onions i have
cooked onions in my steak and i have
habanero peppers and they're hot as heck
and jalapenos and i have seen like you
know the red pepper flakes and i have
some real hot sauce that sometimes i use
and ketchup if you prefer ketchup you
can do that too okay okay i'm gonna put
this on mine only need one cause they're
hard of head okay and then i'm gonna
roll mine i've always wanted to learn
how to make a philly cheesesteak and i
was lucky enough to go to philadelphia
once and eat in like a proper
flat top awesome like philly cheese
steak dive and it was everything that i
hoped it would be well you're doing it
right today
so then i i'll cut this wrap patty
i heard um that uh you knew richard
pryor is this true
oh god we we toured a lot together
richard pryor and myself and he always
felt as though he wasn't paying me
enough cash so he would always give me
gifts
he said beautiful diamonds to my home
and on the road we were in detroit and
he wanted to buy his op
uh car and like he said happen to pick
out a car from my own i said what color
is her hair he says like gray bluish
gray so i found this beautiful blue soft
blue like my fingernails and this color
car
and i said and he said sit in it i said
okay he said now here's the key he said
this is your new car
richard i don't drive him and my
husband's gonna kill me because we have
two cars and why is people say where'd
you get that car from richard pryor
because he loves you and so we ended up
with with three cars and he's such a
great he was such a wonderful man and
the funniest man i know i i yes i've
always had
a thing for comedians because i do feel
like they're healers
and i was such a big richard pryor fan
growing up so i had to ask because he is
such a legend he he he and yes now my
cheese is melted
oh pat this looks really good that looks
perfect you should put some sea pepper
some real hot flakes on
if you have them or some habanero
peppers and ketchup if you like okay i
went peppers banana peppers cheese and
meat oh
nice okay ready
well just do it okay ready
um
it's good yeah
it's really good let me see you too how
did you chew how do you choose room but
it's even worse patty i'm not kidding i
don't even care
is this weird that i'm going around the
top like a
typewriter no it's not weird you're
doing it the way you have to honey do
you know what my very favorite food is
on planet earth yeah
it's macaroni and cheese
oh i got you i needed somebody passing
to me so yeah i love macaroni and i have
some for you i'm so excited i'm gonna
get to try the very famous patty labelle
macaroni and cheese right now i'm
putting my hair back okay honey
you want me to put some on the plate for
you oh i'm eating right out of the pan
patty
[Laughter]
you're my kind of girl go ahead and it's
so good i'm not bragging
but it's awesome this is exactly how i
love macaroni and cheese and when it
deviates from this i feel like it's not
macaroni and cheese you completely
nailed it this is exactly what macaroni
and cheese this is the dream this is the
everest of mac and
go to walmart and get it honey because
this show is selling
and
no meal would be complete without
shoving
another bite of food
i'm so excited i get to try your sweet
potato pie that sells 36 000 pies a day
yes you've never tasted it right no this
is my first
oh girl okay ready
you're my kind of girl
oh wow
the cinnamon
and the spices it's so incredibly
flavorful oh yeah thank you your food it
is love
and you can taste it and you can feel it
this was so much fun thank you so much
for having me on your wonderful show oh
my goodness thank you sweetie patty
labelle so much paddy's good life frozen
foods are available at walmart and other
stores as well
and patty's philly cheesesteak recipe is
going to be on our website i can't
recommend it more
thank you
[Music]
you